and finally new rule nothing with crypto
in the title ever turns out good
there is a mania rising in the country
these days about cryptocurrency
and how the train is leaving the station
so you better get on
tesla has jumped in with both feet and
microsoft accepts it for software now
xe etsy accepts it now and so does
paypal and starbucks and whole foods and
home depot
one in 10 americans use their stimulus
checks
to invest in one of thousands of
cryptocurrencies in existence
bitcoin being the most famous but
there's also ethereum
binance tether even one called come
rocket
there's also one called dogecoin that
someone started as a joke but
as far as i can tell it's exactly the
same as all the other cryptocurrencies
because the whole thing is a joke
i fully understand that our financial
system isn't perfect but at least it's
real
apple stock is worth money because apple
makes thousand dollar phones that
everyone buys and then drops in the
toilet
[Laughter]
but dogecoin recently rallied to be
worth more than the market cap of
ford and kraft foods and it has no
product
and no workers it's just easter bunny
cartoon cash
i've read articles about cryptocurrency
i've had it explained to me and i still
don't get it and neither do you
or anyone else
and i'll explain why
so there's these things called nerds
and in 2008 one of them we don't know
who because this person or group of
persons is still anonymous
made up bitcoin out of thin air using
the fake name
satatoshi nakamoto which i think are the
japanese words for monopoly money
now now capitalism of course
has always contained an element where
instead of actually making something or
providing a service for
money you could make money in the
exciting field
of money but we knew money had to
originate
from and be generated by something real
somewhere
to which cryptocurrency says no it
doesn't
maybe this is why warren buffett says
cryptocurrencies basically have no value
and they don't produce
anything what you hope is that somebody
else comes along and pays you more money
for them later on
but then that that person's got the
problem
in terms of value zero
or as another analyst put it it's an
open ponzi scheme
it's like having an imaginary best
friend who's also a banker
this is how the world economy crashed in
2009
it wasn't the lost value in actual
houses that sunk us it was this virtual
market
that required inventing algorithms to
bet on how much houses might be worth in
a virtual
virtual scenario but then the landlord
called in the bill for this virtual
market because in adult land it turns
out the landlord is always real
our problem here is at roots not
economic but
psychological people who have been
raised in a virtual world
are starting to believe they can really
live in it
much of warfare is a video game now
why not base our economy the same way
and cryptocurrency
is literally a game bitcoins are created
by what they call
mining mining but not the kind of mining
that's done by
seven dwarves who share a woman
this kind of mining involves using rooms
full of super computers to make
something that is purposefully arbitrary
essentially
one computer thinks of a number between
one and infinity
and other computers take trillions of
guesses at what it is
it's the old game of i'm thinking of a
number between 1 and 10
except times a gazillion and the guy
guessing the number lives in china and
the guy who knows the number lives in
the matrix
take that work
do i need to spell this out there is
something inherently not credible
about creating hundreds of billions in
virtual wealth with nothing ever
actually being accomplished
and no actual product made or service
rendered
it's like tinkerbell's light its
power source is based solely on enough
children believing in it
and unfortunately what israel
is the unfathomable amount of
electricity those
massive supercomputers suck up for their
mining
the power listen to this the power being
used right now to guess numbers and win
imaginary prizes
is the same as all the electricity
needed to light all of new york
state except the governor's office where
they use romantic candles
bitcoin uses more electricity per
transaction than any other method known
to mankind
just one uses more energy than a million
visa transactions
and has the same carbon footprint as 85
000
hours of watching youtube what a 15 year
old calls the weekend
bitcoin uses more energy than netflix
apple facebook microsoft and google
combined
i mean cars are bad for the climate but
at least they take you somewhere
in tiger woods case a tree
but this this this is just a
beanie baby that runs on coal how can a
company like
tesla be all in on saving the planet
with electric cars
and then participate in destroying it
with this completely unnecessary online
play money
almost
almost all the people who tout bitcoin
and dealing bitcoin and who won't shut
the [ __ ] up about bitcoin
the millennials the gen zers the silicon
valley types these are all the same
people who see themselves as hip and
progressive and big environmentalists
[ __ ] you're money-hungry
opportunists and you're not allowed to
pretend you care about the environment
according to the journal nature
bitcoin's growth
could single-handedly push global
temperatures above the tipping point of
two degrees celsius
i know melting ice caps can wait your
green new deal involves cash
social scientists call this cognitive
dissonance a disconnect between who you
think you are
and what you actually do i call it being
full of [ __ ]
you